we wanted to make sure that we still had
the DNA of Fast and Furious movies big
action set-pieces
defying gravity around every corner
where you're like wait is that possible
what the bass appears it's cool get
ready for this action-packed film
starting to eat Johnson I'm what you
call a nice cold can of whoop-ass and
Jason Statham
I'm will you my collection by Bubba its
Hobbes and Shaw the first spin-off from
The Fast and Furious franchise here's
everything you need to know before you
go
[Music]
fans fell in love with Dominic Toretto
Brian O'Conner and ex-cop and their crew
of illegal street racers in the first
four Fast and Furious films the stories
were comprised of races with high
rewards and even higher stakes
but let's fast forward too fast in the
Furious Five where the storytelling in
the series switches gears cars become
less of the focal point instead speed
racing supported a new narrative
revolving around heists heavy with
action Luke Hobbs was introduced to the
franchise as a tough Diplomatic Security
Service agent let's go hon his mission
was to capture Dom a fugitive and his
crew after they stole cars that were
seized by the DEA
one of the cars contained a computer
chip which belonged to crime lord Aaron
Andreas that held the location of a
hundred million dollars they say well
Hobbs tracked them down in Brazil with a
team of agents after some intense
chasing Hobbs and his men eventually
arrested Dom Mia Brian and Vince while
and transport their own horse by Reyes
as men and Hobbes's agents are killed in
the attack along with Vince
to avenges team Hobbs joins forces with
DOM and his crew to finish the heist and
take down Dre us all ride with you
Toretto least until would kill that son
of a [ __ ]
Dom and his crew steal the ball
containing Reyes is 100 million dollars
and Hobbs let's DOM and Brian go free by
giving them a 24 hour head start come
tomorrow I will find you
after they leave Hobbs opens up the
vault and it's empty
and the mid-credits scene hobbes
discovers Dom's wife Lettie is alive and
involved in a hijack of a military
convoy in Berlin led by Owen Shaw in
Fast & Furious 6
Owen Shaw the main antagonist of the
film is stealing components to assemble
a destructive device called the
nightshade that he'll sell to the
highest bidder simplest things can cause
the biggest problems this was taken a
week ago I need your help Donna given
their experience Hobbs sees Dom's crew
as the best fit to track down Shaw's
team of mercenary drivers you get as
close to Letty and we'll get you Shaw
and you give us full pardons all the way
around
[Music]
in their final pursuit of shahe is
seriously injured upon being thrown from
a plane
daaamn gives hobbes the computer-chip
the final piece needed to power the
nightshade thus securing the crews
pardons and ability to return to the US
while in a car chase in Tokyo Han is hit
by an oncoming car
Domenic to rap yeah you don't know me
you were about to am furious seven doms
crew are enjoying normal lives back in
the u.s. meanwhile Deckard Shaw Owens
older brother is swearing vengeance
against them wish now that brother
I'll show you one nostril Deckard broke
in Ahab's office to extract files on
Dom's crew leading to a fight that
landed Hobbs in the hospital
while attending Hans funeral in la dumb
notices Shah is there watching in a car
nearby he please just as open fire is
unleashed by a covert ops team led by
mr. nobody mr. nobody offers to assist
Dom and stopping Shah if they help him
rescue Ramsey and her computer program
God's eye a digital device that helps
track people down
Shaw is defeated in a one-on-one fight
with Dom Hobbs locks him up in a secret
high-security prison DOM is coerced into
working for cyber terrorists cipher did
you ever think you'd betray your family
the way you did today
shortly after Hobbs recruits Dom and the
team to help him retrieve an EMP device
from a military outpost in Berlin during
the getaway Dom goes rogue to steal the
device for cipher Hobbs is arrested and
placed in the same prison as Shaw mr.
nobody hacked the prison system to free
Hobbs and Shaw I said no mr. nobody I'm
not leaving this cell rubber bullets big
mistake
[Applause]
[Music]
after which mr. nobody approaches them
to help him track down DOM and cypher we
also learned that cypher is holding Dom
son as well as his former lover hostage
thus revealing why he's working for her
Magdalene shop pushes Decker to save
Dom's son cementing him as a not so bad
guy was this one Deckard connects the
dots for the team he reveals that cypher
hired the villains in the previous film
to steal the nightshade and God's eye
and that brings us up to speed for Hobbs
in sha our targets name is Brixton is it
ghost we're gonna need the best trackers
in the business you guys have to work
together
no way this guy's a realist
I think it'll be pretty fresh to me it's
almost like asset preparation and story
I think it would just sauce a girlfriend
for the first time on the big screen in
a tentpole global movie the Samoan
culture is being exposed and showcased
all right for the movie to descend upon
this little island in the South Pacific
where the fate of the world lies in this
islets just really beautiful and is very
personal
sure sister took something from me the
first time you really see her she should
eat something
nothing you have no idea what would deal
with it just was like I just adored
doing this sequence me and him are
fighting a bit and he kept going yeah
are you making sounds of the fight while
you're doing things that oh my god I
didn't realize so now you know and now
you can go see a pause
oh sure yeah Hobbs and Shaw and theatres
August 2nd
[Music]